foreign
ister
do you know what is about to happen
do you know what store
Walmart
Target no
this is a very special store because
something big is gonna happen tomorrow
yeah really big you want some hints
yeah do you want a clue
okay so we're gonna get toy so there's
gonna be we're gonna buy like three toys
and we're gonna buy them we're gonna buy
a bed that's like the size of this
Square
do you know why
and we're gonna buy a bone
I don't know what do you think why do
you think I'm gonna go to a store and
buy a bed this size and then buy a bone
[Music]
excuse me
do you think you haven't figured out do
you know what we're going to the store
for
so silly you crazy bones
[Applause]
hey mister
I know you know how to read now or at
least a little bit
what does that say
p e t
what does pet say
pet did you help him
do you know what you get at the pet
store
no we're getting a puppy tomorrow
who just told me you were gonna say
anything I can't help it look how cute
this guy's face is I can't help it okay
monkey but today but today we're gonna
get a dog tomorrow a puppy we're gonna
get a puppy tomorrow
it's too it's too late but we're gonna
get all the stuff that we need first
okay what do you think we need
what do you think we need to buy her
our new puppy that we're gonna pick up
tomorrow what do you think we need so
they need a bed to sleep
and
you're Georgie I know
what'd you see
what was it a chair for a lizard is that
a chair for a lizard house and you get
all cozy and comfortable you know what
bread is that
[Applause]
do you think there's any puppies in the
fish tanks what
are you crazy
all right first thing we need to get
Mister is food
doggies need food okay
so the shelter that we're adopting the
puppy from they said that they have her
on Blue Buffalo puppy
and the Costco one so it's really
important to get what they already have
that way you don't switch dye up too
much and then give the puppy or the dog
diarrhea and if you want to switch it
over to whatever dog food you have they
usually say you transition it so you'll
start with like 75 25 by 25 the new dog
food then after a couple days 50 50 then
after a couple days 75-25 and the other
dogs with favor and then finally it's
100 so that way their dogs a little
tummies get used to it
I thought you knew this I thought you're
as much of a dog Master as I am about
what about what about like if you want
to switch a dog dog's um like dog food
you go to transition you don't want to
just like 180 flip because you'll have
diarrhea exactly like you want to do 75
25
75 to like not tell me everything so I'm
like what did they say well because I
assume you're really smart like me but
then I'll assume the other way around
well how are you really smart if people
have to tell you no they don't have to
tell me anything these are things I know
no you don't no you are you no you
I see you
no I just see the sign up there says
Blue Buffalo
yep right there boo Buffalo
oh there's a green one there's a blue
one
brown rice and
with Savory I want high protein whoa
Healthy Growth formula oh the meat head
right here is gonna want that for sure
and then that one has carbs and no one
has no carbs oh
what dogs go keto I don't know
what do you look like
oh you're right where did you see dog
food
um
oh I forgot my grandma has two dogs two
big dogs
excuse me
Roxy you're right she did
Roxy did
all right right right I forgot
super smart
oh my God how do you know that Theo
rather over
told you that yeah who told you that he
knows all of the family trees
so we just got the dog food they said
they feed him this one the teal bag of
the Baby Blue Buffalo the dog does look
like this so looks like it matches
so now we need to get a toy we gotta
find a toy what is that oh excuse me
already you do which one monkey Cheeto
you gotta get some dog toys
and we need a dog bed too
and we probably need that yes smart
look how comfy these are whoa this is
comfy are you just want to be a dog
I need this would be perfect but what if
they get big what's a large oh it's a
large and they curl up right
you think you're getting a great perfect
really yes she's a puppy dude yeah but
she's gonna get big okay just as
like are you a puppy you are a puppy
I got a puppy already
hey you look so comfy why do you look so
comfortable no put your arms up put your
arms back up I'm just I'm just putting
that yeah
I'm gonna take a picture it'll go like
this
give me a big smile put your hats behind
the head
crazy bones
[Applause]
yeah they're wearing the dog bed
what
do we need this
cream
is insane okay what are we gonna say Ben
and Jerry
you gotta be this is nuts this is are
you some people don't have kids and this
is their kids okay yeah but I mean no
there's no I mean where do you find a
Ben and Jerry's in the forest you just
asked me if we were gonna get two dog
beds one for the one area of the house
and one for the other what are you
talking about but they make their own
natural dog beds at um your Forest yeah
so they don't need two dude
okay monkey so with puppies or dogs they
need a collar do you know where this
goes
yeah and why do they need that
chocolate you put the leash on and that
way you can walk them you put a leash on
and then if you want to walk them you
walk them with this
yeah so so the dog we're picking up it's
gonna be a girl okay which one would you
like to get her there's all of those too
I don't want her to be a boy well it's
not gonna be a boy it's gonna be a girl
we'll get a boy next but for now the
first one's gonna be a girl okay
the second one's gonna be a boy so which
one do you want to get for her
look at all the different ones
just keep looking you'll see if there's
something else you like that one no no
let him keep looking
okay it doesn't have to be pinky either
monkey
even though my favorite color is only
one only one
I don't know what the bow tie don't
point the camera at me
is that the one you want I like that
this is a really nice color that is a
really pretty color but this one has a
bow
but it goes on her neck this one's going
on the puppy not you
so which one which one
there's more over here look at the other
ones there's a bunch of other ones yeah
you missed it look there's like these
over here too there's like this one
there's different ones look this one has
bananas on it that one has little bones
yep any other ones
[Music]
foreign
any other ones
all right which do you want dude
what about the one that Papa has in his
hand you like this
one I'll tell you which one I like I
like this one
oh no
when you let a five-year-old someone has
a diet then I know but that's what Paris
Hilton would want
what a reference
all right we'll uh we'll get it then
okay we'll get a toy we'll get a toy
now taika's favorite part getting dog
toys fun fact taika actually his
favorite stuffed toy right now that he's
had for maybe a year now and they talk
and they play together and they're like
best friends because I was actually a
dog chew toy monkey Cheeto I'll show
them to you when and tiger no tiger we
used to be your pacifier
I just cut off the pacifier but yeah
that's Tiger's favorite toy so we found
out monkey that
um she likes ropes we need to help her
pick a little rope toy there's this
roped here
there's this duckle up with this Duck
Club
hello
oh that's CUNY yeah that's a cool one
this one
it's been a minute because we were
totally forgetting that we needed a dog
bowl for uh food and water and we forgot
we needed a pooper scooper we're getting
all the fun stuff the bed the toys and
then we're like oh yeah the survival
like dog yeah even this forgot about
that I was like we need to brush teeth
oh go ahead we used to have all these
things but then when we moved and
everyone like passed away we you know
just got rid of everything you know we
haven't had a dog in a year and a half
so it's coming back to us
[Applause]
all right Papa we got all of this
and all of this
how much you think we're spending
I think maybe close to 500 bucks what do
you
think
I'm thinking the same but give me a
number
[Music]
420. okay I'm gonna go with 5 30. oh we
do over 500 yeah let's see what happens
all right taika how much money do we're
gonna spend 100
000 billion million okay I think you
lost all right let's try it let's try it
so we just left PetSmart what's the
damage who won
they might as well call it the casino or
the freaking trained us of all the money
hold on who won you did no taika won
because I said 5 30. yeah and I went
over
isn't he the closer one a hundred
thousand million billion yeah but isn't
he closer no to a hundred dollars you
win
you win
so now we are at Marshalls because taika
got invited to one of his classmates
birthday party
um and I always have the best mom hacks
and you guys should do this too
um so moms every time there's these
birthday parties that invited to I never
like going Anthony you don't want your
kid to go empty-handed and not bring a
present but we also don't know these
kids and we don't know the relationship
or whatever but you still want to again
not go empty-handed so I always come to
Marshalls and then ask the parents or
first ask the parents hey what is your
kid into then they let me know
um and then I come to Marshalls and I
find the best most perfect gift for such
an affordable price so one of his
classmates um he likes space stuff so
Papa found this can I can I see it yeah
I found this thing
is tucked away in the corner there's
only one of one yes and it's perfect
it's space I've never even seen this
anywhere uh and how much is it this one
is 25 bucks affordable pricing yep and
then taika got what are you getting Duty
he's getting a register because he's
always playing Star at home yeah so at
least this way we can count and play
with money
six dollars that's just 29 pieces
yep and then I also got taika it's not
tyco's birthday I understand but I also
got him this match it so he's going to
learn animal families he's gonna learn
his first words he's gonna learn all
about me and then mathematics and this
is 17
yes baby
yeah we're gonna do a lot of math and
learning at home
we're going to learn about Commerce huh
yeah of course but just not right now of
course
yeah of course
I I what are you guys playing the star
game store yeah who's the store owner uh
well tiger was but now I am and he says
that he has
um oh so I thought he was a regular door
to open that goes tingling and he goes
no mama they're the ones that open like
this duh
oh that's true that's true I like that
you protect mama like that that's right
I can't talk to your mama like that
okay Mr customer all right customer
for business
hey tiger how are you
uh lucky guess
did you just fart yeah
welcome how can I help you good oh okay
good that works
hmm you gotta you got a party wow that's
a lot of food
wow you're a hungry boy huh
yeah oh whoa
I think you're running out of basket
space sir
oh okay is that everything yeah thank
you so much uh will you be paying cash
or credit today
Cash Cash okay
I got one hand on the chips one hat on
the money is it spicy
you got water over there
got some pork rinds
from uh the Star this morning
it's kind of spicy for them
oh you're actually charging every single
one that's cute yeah I don't know how
you guys that's true that's true
is this your dream job remember
you said if you could have any like like
just like aimless just repetitive job
you would love to be uh excuse me sir
six coins please okay let me pack it
right up I love this so much this is my
dream job you're so right no wonder I'm
like in it that's skinny
six items oh
you put it in here please
well that thing goes inside that's
pretty cool
[Applause]
oh you paid seven coins hold on one more
extra coin
I have to give you no no that's too many
coins you gave too many coins yeah
that's your change that's your change
[Music]
what
he fell in the store he's gonna sue you
now
so taika is going to start running a
ketogenic diet
an efforts of um holistically healing
and helping with his seizures so that I
could wean him off his medication
because it's just not working for us and
I'm not gonna do that to my child
anymore yeah
you're my baby yeah I trusted the
medical system and it's just not working
so
um I've done a ton of research and I'm
moving in an alternative Direction uh so
yeah because he's going into more of a
ketogenic diet
he can eat pork rinds
and these are actually spicy
they're not spicy for you
oh okay I'm done in the water okay see
you later
but yeah if your kid
um or you know anyone you know suffers
from uh seizures I'm not a doctor
obviously but there's um go online and
check out ketogenic diet for seizures
and see if that might be an alternative
route for you to take uh we haven't
completely fully started on it just yet
but I'm slowly moving him in that
direction
um he's still taking his medication but
like I said we will start weaning him
off of it of course under the
supervision of a full ass team so we're
gonna have a neurologist this
pediatrician
um a diet a diet dietitian
um and just a whole ass team of doctors
backing us up every single step of the
way so
yeah so if you start seeing him uh
eating things like pork rinds or keto
bars or whatever and you know where it's
coming from oh it's Papa's turn
the door's right here
oh we got a nice store in here
whoa the AC is cold in here oh
[Music]
I could bring snacks got some yummy
stuff what do you recommend well what's
recommended means recommends means you
like this so you think I should get some
I like which one do you like yeah tell
what do you recommend what do you think
Papa should buy
oh man
he's just it's a what is it Black Friday
sale you got a lot of inventory the
apple juice is good
a good one here okay
the monsters the monsters in the store
is the this good the macaroni and cheese
yeah
I do pretty good what about this is very
good vegetables yeah
yeah
should I get strawberries or the grapes
no that's too much I think my bathroom
only fit doesn't much can you charge me
up yep see how much it is
thank you
purple great
yeah yeah
and strawberries
strawberries
scan again
wow
[Music]
thank you peas green peas
thank you
hey why she do that
yummy yummy for my boat
one coins total total yeah
that's a good deal over here
one coin
yeah I gotta take his money take his
money what kind of store is this
yeah charge it
hey that's credit card fraud I think
are you stealing what in the
this store I didn't even call the police
I don't know what is happening